hey I'm ready my name is Bailey and this
is my boy Ethan you enjoying the breeze
Bostock I've lived a lot of lives as a
lot of different dogs but I always found
my way back to II finding out that isn't
getting any easier that is getting an
easier
this is CJ the greatest new addition to
our package hmm there's nothing in that
Cup I love mornings with our
granddaughter
so did I mostly because she gave me
bacon
do you ever taking a bath with the
filthy dog I just having fun
Oh CJ's mom wants to play too or not
pretty soon CJ had to move away once
don't rewind up I wanted to chase the
card but I just didn't have the energy
[Music]
and then it happened I was a puppy again
and CJ was my new purpose she was a
gigantic baby now what is she saying no
idea CJ I have a date tonight
again I could always tell when my girl
needed me when you
as soon as I can I'm getting out of here
I'm gonna move to New York City wait I
smell my boy even it's me really thank
you what makes you think you can just
show up like this we want to see our
granddaughter please you just keep
taking care CJ big dog you didn't get up
for anything no matter how many lives it
took I would be there for CJ oh hello
where did you come from like he chose
you things don't always turn out as we
planned but sometimes the surprises are
the best part ride your drum baby don't
stop readin
there's luck you don't know about that
[Music]
I don't have all the answers
but I know we end up where we're meant
to be home like a drum my heart never
stops beating for you seriously don't
think you got one in your boss dog okay
you ready born ready one two three go go
bus stop oh that isn't getting any
easier oh that isn't getting it easier
ah after all the excitement of the day
I had to cool off in the big water ball
I'd leave her with you for a couple
hours and you have clarity bathing with
a filthy dog finally hurry wants to play
just play alright get out get out dog
fine you know what don't worry honey
mommy's here come on it's okay no I get
what you want me to do
this is why I don't like dogs maybe you
wanted to stick your nose in my butt
today was a good day
why finally got a call from the cruise
line Gloria spent a lot of time talking
to her hand and they needed a singer for
their stage coach lounge no there's
nothing in that cup did you make me a
cup delicious delicious wait there was
something in that Cup
that girl there's something about that
girl
I smell something familiar I can't let
him down
got to get to CJ I don't got this I'm so
happy you and rocky are a good match CJ
it's me I'm here to protect you CJ was a
gigantic baby now Gloria it's good to
see you I made girls a surprise for you
look even look we wanted to see you we
want to see CJ we don't want to see you
which is why even it's me Billy can't
you tell it's me is that you Buster it's
me it's me it's me this box has smells
like sorry this way
[Music]
Trane's CJ
where's Rocky wow this is so weird my
dog just dragged me here but I don't
know um do you live here yeah I just
moved in
who's this little guy oh um that's max
be careful he's not very friendly
oh right I'm so glad to see you where's
Rocky he seems pretty feeling to me hi
if it's W Bruce Cameron on the
screenwriter here for a Dodge Journey
we're on set but which of the dogs are
your favorite oh gosh you know how do
you choose look hell no loan he is is he
just had a massage or something he's had
a lot of training and even though this
is his first big film is really getting
used to the star treatment now is he
playing a beagle in the movie or is he
playing like a husky he's playing a baby
so when they're waving that chicken
around do you ever get like oh I really
like a bite of that chick thank God no I
noticed it on set the dogs are giving
treats and they're kept warm why aren't
the screenwriters treated like that I
thought you were oh I got some state
fits backing one will help you I'm gonna
have to go for the steak cakes here dogs
are the best part of the movie
[Music]
this is my dog peaches say hello say all
right thank you bye Dennis is fantastic
with the dogs
hello Oh peaches she goes everywhere
with me just goes I'm plain she goes to
the car with me goes our meetings those
she just likes to hang just talking I've
always been a dog person I've always had
thought dogs give you comfort they're
your friend
they're family to us that's what they
really find up a comic there's a lot you
don't know about that dog I don't have
all the answers but I know we end up
where we're meant to be
[Music]